[Music]
hey everyone how's it going hope you are
well
so i'm really excited about today's
video because i'm going to talk about my
work from home desk setup for software
engineers
a lot of software engineers and tech
industry folks have moved from working
in the office to their at-home desk
setup so today i wanted to talk to you
about my own
and for those of you who are new here hi
welcome my name is mayuko and on this
channel we talk about the tech industry
careers in tech and also just lifestyle
things as well so make sure to check out
the rest of my channel and consider
subscribing
i did a video about my desktop last year
but it's changed a tiny bit and so i
want to talk about all the upgrades and
give you an overview of everything
so you might be watching this video for
some inspiration or just to shop around
different options
and so in order to do that i've invited
my friend jossey to talk about his desk
setup as well
what is going on everyone my name is
josie lynn j
thank you mayuko for having me on your
channel where i get a chance to share
my setup as a software engineer software
developer as well
on my channel i make similar content
remember dana life of a software
engineer i also make content about
my experiences as a computer science
major along with you know currently
working as a front end dev
along with my full stack experience in
this video we're going to talk about
half of our desk setups
the other half is going to be in a video
on his channel so make sure to check
that out
so without further ado let's do this
thing
[Music]
so for my desk i have the jarvis
standing desk from foley
in my previous job i was given a
standing desk and i loved using it
having the option to sit and stand
throughout the workday just really gave
me that level of flexibility and kind of
kept me moving throughout the day
because as you know as developers we
spend
so much time at our desks and so having
something that allows me to move freely
and be flexible
has really been a major add to my life
and if you're wondering
yes i do actually sit and stand
throughout the day i stand for about an
hour and then i sit for about an hour
and i just kind of go back and forth
between the two
like many standing desks you can
customize this one a ton i got the 60
inch table top in bamboo with white legs
and i just really like the look of the
bamboo tabletop too it's just a really
pretty color
and it looks really nice i got the
programmable keypad just so that i make
sure that i'm always standing at the
right height and sitting at the right
height and i'm not cheating on either
so my desk has evolved over the past
year year and a half because one i've
been making more content on youtube
along with working remotely for like
seven or
eight months so i've made sure that my
desk
is not only economic but it's functional
and it looks nice it inspires me
and motivates me to get whatever like
work that i have to get done
but you don't want to break the bank so
as you can probably tell
the items that i purchased for this test
setup are from
ikea if we start with the countertop
i have a irk bakken i think that's how
you pronounce it
bakken countertop it's 74 inches long at
first i thought it was gonna be too long
but trust me it's the perfect length if
you want to have enough space
especially if you're someone like myself
who has like a personal laptop
to work laptops and maybe like an ipad
and you're using like a bluetooth
keyboard
and monitor and like you know audio
system
all those things add up and can take up
a lot of your space
which is why i upgraded from that 40
like seven
inch linmon countertop that i got from
ikea
my desk setup is influenced from a more
like modern
scandinavian design where it's very
simple
minimal silhouettes also we have white
walls
surrounding us everywhere in this
apartment which is also a pretty
minimalistic
apartment in terms of the design and
the layout so that was the main reason
why i wanted to go with like a wooden
countertop because i didn't like
having a really white bland wall with
like a white counter space
it just didn't feel right moving on to
the drawers
the alex drawers are great especially if
you're someone who's working from home
or studying from home
and you have like a lot of you know
paperwork that you're keeping track of
i use a lot of these drawers to store a
lot of the boxes and chargers
that go to the devices that i'm not only
using for my desk setup but maybe
accessories for like my ipad pro my
laptop and my phone
we don't have a lot of closet space in
this apartment so being able to take
advantage of having
drawers underneath my countertop has
made a huge difference
it's decluttered my space significantly
there are a few
other things that i recommend everyone
add
to their desk setup one are plants
especially if your desk is pretty
minimal is that a fly that just went
past
there are a couple things that i do
recommend everyone add to their desk
setup
and one are plants plants just
add this sense of like peacefulness
and like serenity okay i'm getting a
little deep
plants just make your desk feel a little
bit more fresh
and it doesn't seem so like sterile
along with the fact that it adds a pop
of color
you know a little contrast the next
thing that i recommend having
is a desk pad the reason being is
because
one it adds another pop of color maybe
like a contrast like a neutral color
like gray
would make your desk pop a little bit
more i don't know
it's great for b-roll too it keeps your
desk a lot
more clean i mean i don't spill like
drinks on my desk that often
but when i have it's prevented like the
countertop from getting ruined
so for monitors i opted for a two
monitor setup
so these are the two same monitors that
i did in my desk setup video linked
right here in this card
and the main difference is that now
they're both horizontal and i opted for
a monitor stand
i prefer having two monitors over one
because then i can pin windows to more
corners and it feels like i've just got
more space
and so a lot of times i'll have my
coding ide on one monitor
and then stack overflow and slack on the
other and also sometimes i run two
computers at once and so having two
monitors
one for each computer has been really
handy in monitor size wise i found that
27 inch is a perfect size for me
it's bigger than my laptop screen but
not so big that i feel like i'm part of
the computer
the monitor it's it's everything in
terms of aesthetics i thought that a
dual display was best for me because
i do a lot of css you could imagine that
my
files can be really long when i'm
writing styles for
so many different pages on a website so
you'll see a lot of front-end developers
flipping their monitor vertically which
seems really weird but you can help with
productivity especially when you have
like
a file that's over a thousand lines of
code but one thing i noticed is that i
never actually flipped my monitor
vertically
so i've really been loving this 34 inch
ergo qhd ultra wide monitor has a 21x9
ratio
allowing me to be as productive as
possible
but with the ultra wide i can take
advantage of that which is really
helpful for when
i'm multitasking with like stack
overflow visual studio code
along with looking at what my web
application
looks like in browser which is the big
difference between
mobile dev and like front-end
development with building websites
when you're building an application with
web you really need like a whole nother
screen
to actually look at your application you
want to make sure that it's responsive
that's always important for me to
actually have an ultra wide opposed to a
dual monitor display
a few features i loved about this ultra
wide monitor
is the display which is at 3440 by 1440
i'm able to extend retract swivel
change the height and the tilt of the
monitor
along with a three side virtually
borderless
design which is really minimal and
doesn't distract me at all
of course it has the 99 color gamut amd
freesync which is something you'd really
appreciate as
someone who games using your monitor
along with it being color calibrated
which is something i actually
really need considering the fact that my
main
personal laptop which is my dell xps 15
is over
saturated
for my keyboard i use a developer
favorite this is the mx
keys the one that i have specifically is
for mac and so the keyboard layout is
specifically designed for a mac layout
i really really like this keyboard the
build quality
is really great it doesn't feel too
plasticky and it's got some really neat
features
one of my favorite parts is that it
glows right when you approach it which
kind of feels like a nice
warm welcome from my keyboard to my desk
and the best part about it like
most logitech keyboards is that you can
program the keys to your liking
and so i have specific key bindings
mostly for applications that i run
like my coding ide like my video editing
software
and it's made my workflow just so much
more efficient and smooth
this paired with a mouse that i talk
about in jossie's video are just
i feel like every developer needs them
it's just so nice
it really does help with your workflow
and so i recommend it to like
everybody and although it's not a split
ergonomic keyboard i find that it suits
my needs
but for those long coding sessions
sometimes i will without my ergonomic
keyboard for logitech
your typing experience is important and
i've tried a few different ways to
improve
my typing experience and the easiest way
to do that
is by trying out different keyboards the
ergo k860 keyboard has been
my go-to when programming because of the
split
economic layout which improves the
typing posture
and reduces muscle strain as a software
developer you can imagine
how much more time we spend typing and
having a more relaxed
experience for my shoulders wrists and
forearms
which has made my experience working for
longer time frames better
at first the design of this keyboard
looked a bit unconventional
but as soon as i started typing the
layout actually felt
more natural and comfortable than a more
normal layout
[Music]
so i'm someone that loves listening to
music while i work it gives me the
energy that i need it helps me get into
the flow and most of the time i'm
listening to chill hop lo-fi
sometimes i listen to like classical
music sometimes i listen to just like
chill nice music to work to other times
i just listen to like certified bops
because i just need to get my energy up
regardless the main way that i listen to
my music is through these bose speakers
now i think this is kind of one of like
the best parts about working from home
because you can actually play your music
through speakers and through
headphones because you're not in an
office and so i really like these
speakers
the sound is much much higher quality
than the sound that comes from my
macbook pro and everything is really
crisp and things can get really loud
it connects using an aux cable and so i
can just plug it in directly to my mac
super easily i actually used to have a
really old old version of these
and i did wonder whether i really needed
them when i bought them but
now i'm just so glad that i did i do use
headphones on occasion still like i'll
use my air pods when i'm on a phone call
or something but
these bose speakers are my main having a
nice set of speakers
can actually make a huge difference
like i didn't realize that until i got
my first pair of like
legit speakers basically bluetooth
speakers over 50 dollars i've been using
the logi
z207 speakers for the past
month or so and honestly they look even
better in person
the sound quality is exceptional the
only complaint is that it's a little bit
too much bass
but when consuming content it sounds
great
these low gz207 speakers provide a rich
stereo sound
that does really fill the room you can
easily pair these speakers with multiple
devices and i really like the easy
controls
making it simple to turn them on and off
and connect them
to bluetooth and that's it make sure to
check out the other half of this video
on jossie's channel where we talk about
computers
mice lighting and chairs i really hope
you like this video and it gives you a
little bit of ideas and inspiration for
how you can set up your work from home
desk setup as well
and just definitely make sure to go
check out jossy's channel his stuff is
so good it's aesthetic
he's got a lot of great advice videos
out there too and so everything is going
to be linked in the description box down
below
leave a comment down below and let us
know what are important parts of your
work from home desk setup
make sure to hit the subscribe button if
you'd like to see more videos like this
from me
and i will see you next time bye